the dollar's value is reducing which
hurts people reproducing
you'll face financial hurdles if you're
really fertile
thanks to soaring inflation it now costs
three hundred thousand 000 to raise a
child or 50 for an uber to drop one off
at the fire department
i thought this was america
anyway this is all according to figures
from the brookings institution and
published in the wall street journal
which of course is owned by our parent
company chuck e cheese
they estimate that a married
middle-income couple with a kid born in
2015 would spend about 18 grand a year
to raise the kid just through high
school that covers housing food clothes
health care and recreation
but it only gets the kid through the age
of 17 and does not include piano lessons
dance lessons or bail
so
if you want to send him to college maybe
don't like
why should the kid get to party on your
dime for four years
i say
use that money instead to throw some
ragers of your own
get drunk throw up on the dog spray
paint your neighbor's car either way you
might be glad you spent that hard-earned
cash on yourself
although by the time they get to college
who knows where we'll be anyway an nbc
news poll finds that 74 percent of
americans say the country is headed in
the wrong direction
and just 42 percent approve of the job
president biden's doing
for context even jimmy's hideous jacket
pulls at around 43 percent
so
mr president what gives
hey i get it i get it
you know it's tough raising kids it's
expensive i know that but uh
it pays off in the long run
yeah like i did with hunter he had a
couple of wild oats to sew but then uh
i sent him over that country what was it
called barisma
and uh
uh yeah he did okay for himself
and he sent a couple of potatoes my way
too so
that didn't hurt
so you know
i'm playing the long game man
i'm like that guy uh
what's his name the guy who plays a long
game
uh i don't i don't care
uh all that matters i'm the senator from
the great state of delaware i'm the vice
president i'm the president shut up
oh boy
jimmy i've met your kid
the linkman is he worth 300 grand
i don't know i don't have to worry about
saving for college for two reasons with
lincoln one is obviously his grades okay
it's out of the question but no i have a
son i have a son which means he can get
a women's basketball scholarship
[Applause]
the kid is six five i have a six five
thirteen-year-old he's gonna get a
scholarship but does he know that's your
plan for him
he does now but it was up fast
i mean no i went to community college
and i know it shows a lot on the air but
the point is
but we are over emphasizing the
importance of college number one but
number two as you said the direction the
country is going in we're heading into
everybody for themselves mode if you
look at a presidency okay like an uber
ride 75 of the passengers say the driver
is going down a one-way you know what
i'm saying and i think that's been the
whole administration as a whole if
you've ever sat in the salon for a bad
haircut which clearly i have okay
you know how this starts you sit down
like what's he doing on the sides oh my
god it's too high on the top that's been
this presidency like what's he's doing
on the border oh my god it's too high
with inflation and then you get up and
go i'm never coming here again and
that's biden
[Music]
tyrus do you have any advice for raising
kids in this economy
pay your own time
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i i don't know who they polled because
my mother raised me with my brother in
like 45 in some hand-me-downs so i mean
it's just
it used to be a saying you make it you
make a dollar out of 15 cents i don't
know what these parents are buying yeah
you know it must be all the apple cards
and roblox cards and et cetera bulldozer
parents spend a lot of money i still
raise my kids the same way that my mom
raised me no
yeah
that's it you know
trying no but
real quick uh the reason why people
saying the country's going the other way
when you have an administration whose
only victories are changing names and
adding genders that doesn't really help
with anything else in the latest one
they said that it was pregnant person
remember that brilliant idea
then they decided to change their mind
and let us know that it's going to go
back to pregnant woman as if everyone
here changed it's just it was up there
with new coke and cnn plus the
pregnant person so that's probably why a
lot of people a little concerned about
the way things are going
yeah i don't know douglas though that
it is concerning which is why i think
the number's always too high of the
people like who are these people that
things think yeah the fourth 41 percent
who thinks things are going great i know
who's the 43
where do they find them i don't know
show yourself yeah yeah
um
and but whenever these uh figures come
out about you know how much it's meant
to cost to raise children there's always
a sort of nasty edge to it doesn't it
the economist did this a couple years
ago they called it the child tax yeah
and i remember thinking like there's
something very nasty in the society when
you start to talk about children as
being like a tax on you because like
aren't they
well
you could look at it like that you could
think like when i die i'll leave an
extra 300 000 bucks in my bank account
and that'll show them but
on the other hand you've got kids you
know it's kind of positive i guess the
thing that scares me is you don't know
like if you're going to like them or not
until they're already here but like
they grow talk about that with my
therapist yeah they grow on you uh in a
couple days degan you're a business
anchor
how is this going to continue to get
worse what do you think oh yeah you want
nasty edge let me give you a nasty edge
okay oh okay
i gave i i gave a bottle of perrier the
finger at the cvs the other day because
it was so expensive and the manager goes
yeah and he's just shaking his head
that's how bad inflation is in terms of
this is when i think about having kids
um this you know this these stats only
run through age 17. so there's another
you so i'm not going to pick on lincoln
so make this a girl in my analogy named
lincoln yes
[Laughter]
yeah you gotta you got a kid daughter
college quarter of a million dollars she
gets pregnant by a waiter she met at
shucker's
two days after she graduates
she gets knocked up she marries him
marries him
three kids she eventually leaves him
because his job in it involves um
collecting treasure with a metal
detector on the beach
so he's not really carrying his weight
she moves back into your house at age 35
with the three kids
and you're gonna wind up taking a dirt
nap before you ever get to retire
whoa unless she gets a job on mtv
or at msnbc yeah i mean teen mom i mean
[Laughter]
there are some employment options there
i don't know if any of them are good
kids
you kids don't watch this up next
why the idea of constitutional rights
keeps lefties up at night hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else